foreign
s us up first in Kansas City Zach what's
going on
hey how's it going great how are you hey
not too bad I'm just giving you guys a
call here I kind of got myself in a kind
of a strange financial position here and
wondering if I need to sell my vehicle
in order to kind of reset
you know my life and uh you know kind of
get out of a hole that I put myself in
um I can kind of I can go into this
specific specifics of uh exactly what
happened
the way you're the way you're starting
the call off
um sounds like you are dealing with
shame what what has happened here
well I'm 24 years old
um I'm two years out of college and
unfortunately I kind of got you know
hooked up with the wrong people and what
I mean by that is as I started uh
gambling Sports gambling casino gambling
and
not that I've lost a ton of money but
it's definitely money that I probably
could have used and spent better I lost
about eight thousand dollars in about a
six month span that's a ton of money
yes it's a lot of money and that's the
and I definitely take it on the chin
what I did was irresponsible it was
immature and 100 something that is
self-inflicted and that I did myself
well you are correct and
I also want to suggest that
we live in an ecosystem now that has
made gambling
um seem like the right thing to do
it really helps out the education system
in your particular State it's a fun way
to hang out with your friends and if you
look at the addiction statistics and the
amount of money being spent on this it's
as though your colleges and universities
which have absolutely sold their
freaking souls to this
are just all you know it's a great great
way to spend a weekend with your kids
you all should do heroin together y'all
should all do cocaine it would just make
you all get a lot more work done and
talk a lot faster it's insane
and so in this in a similar fashion
brother yes you did some dumb things and
you're unfortunately you're one of
millions of of other men and women who
are stuck holding the bag on this deal
and at the same time
um since you were 18 years old and you
showed up at this college everyone
around you from your local government
officials to the university that you
attended has told you what a great and
wonderful thing this is and so that's
been in the area you're breathing too so
I I want to it's both and right
yes so how much debt do you have
well I you know the good news is is I
don't have much I have some I do have it
written down and I can kind of go over
it with you and let you know
um exactly where everything is broken
down into okay what's the total
yeah so I have roughly I would say
everything together right around 50 000
in debt that's between student loans
auto loan and just credit card and
that's not much to you
here's the thing I have 17 000 in
student loans I have just under a
thousand in credit cards and thirty
thousand uh auto loan and other than
that that's the only debt that I have
all these words are just the it's the
only debt I just have we got to stop
using these modifiers I want you to feel
like holy crap this is a lot of debt
I am not safe this isn't only a thousand
dollars on the credit card this isn't
only seventeen thousand this is my life
at stake my future hangs in the balance
that's the kind of intensity you need to
be feeling towards this debt if we want
to get out of this hole because if it's
only a thousand then why even pay it off
I mean it's really not even that it's
it's almost zero at that point so I want
you to start to change those words that
you're using to trigger your own brain
to tell yourself I'm not okay
something's got to change
okay are you still gambling now
no I'm uh
just shy of 60 days clean awesome are
all the apps off your phone you don't
have any access to them or anything
no I threw I threw away so when I was
physically going to the casino I had a
player's card and whatnot so all of
those have been trashed um I haven't had
the urge to go I never
um really got involved in online
gambling other than just sports betting
through DraftKings that app has been
deleted um but I have no
um I guess there's nothing at my
fingertips that can allow me to gamble
have you transferred that um initial
addiction onto something else are you
drinking more than normal or staying up
later more than normal
no um I I'm not I've never really been a
drinker I would say the most I ever
Drank in one sitting was probably maybe
a six pack of beer I just really am just
not really into getting I'll say this I
I spent some time I spent some time in
college hungover and it's a feeling that
it's just not uh not something I enjoy
okay well I wasn't focusing less as much
on the alcohol as much as right if we
tell you to sell your car
and you are if you're calling us and you
don't have a gambling addiction
and someone says hey should I sell my
car to get me out of debt and I can
still get my job done I'm working from
home I'm making this kind of money we
might tell you heck yeah I had to sell
your car
if you're an addict
if you're really struggling with
addiction
um and we tell you to sell your car
that's good it's just gonna duct tape
over the problem until tomorrow and it's
going to re-emerge somewhere else and so
if you tell me hey man I had a phase in
college I went bananas I learned an
eight thousand dollar lesson I got hit
in the mouth I'm done with that then
that's that's one path
if you tell me man I am struggling I
want to gamble every day I'm not there
yet then we're going to take another
path
right what's your income not that I'm
trying yeah so my income as of last of
24 years old I'm a Freight Logistics
broker
um as of last year my gross pay was 88
000 great what's the car worth
uh it's worth roughly about fifty five
thousand yes sell it so you're gonna net
25 you're gonna get a real reasonable
car that is not twenty five thousand
dollars probably a ten thousand dollar
car that gives you an extra 15 to pay
off more debt and now we're going to be
debt free within a few months making 88.
that's what I was thinking too but you
can't spend more than 10 grand on a car
so 10 000 is where it needs is the is
the cutoff I just made that number up
but I want it to be a car that you're
gonna have to like kind of duck your
eyes when you walk into your office and
everyone will be like dude we know how
much you make why are you driving that
car
right and here's the reason I need that
you've got to have that carrot dangling
of like man I want to upgrade this car
once I'm out of debt and I have that
emergency fund I'm gonna upgrade this
car and the next time I own a car that I
like it's not going to own me but hey I
want to ask you before we get off the
call you're still you're you're in path
one that we talked about you're not
you're not considered a gambling you
don't have an addiction you're done with
that mess is that fair
just here that's correct all right cool
congratulations my man I'm proud of you
that's a big step the hardest part is
done now he's got to clean up this meth
it's not meth not meth at all John this
mess addiction talk uh clean up this
mess man get rid of that car get
something reasonable get out of debt so
much faster by doing all that and uh
call it a get out of jail free card and
never go back into debt again